bonjour à tous je suis c'est colette et
est aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
l'intercommunalité avant de parler de
l'intercommunalité
combien y at-il de communes en france la
france a plus ou moins trente six mille
six cents communes et compte 66 millions
d'habitants c'est donc une moyenne de
1200 habitants par commune
beaucoup l'ont donc des faibles moyens
humains et financiers
quelle incidence cela at-il sur les
intercommunalités
il est difficile d'imaginer une forte
réduction du nombre de communes c'est
pourquoi des communes ont imaginé de
mutualiser leurs moyens et structurer
les initiatives locales
les auteurs communalité souvenez de ces
rassemblements
et il en existe aujourd'hui 12000
chacune des intercommunalités à la
réunion la réunion au coût de 5
la casud communauté d'agglomération du
sud avec quatre communes la civis
communauté intercommunale des villes
solidaires avec six communes la cinor
communauté intercommunale du nord de la
réunion avec trois communes la cirest
communauté intercommunale réunion ouest
avec six communes et enfin le tc au
territoire de la côte ouest avec six
communes no 24 communes font donc toute
partie d'une intercommunale quels sont
les objectifs d'une intercommunalité il
y a deux objectifs très différents
premier objectif l'intercommunalité gère
certains services de ces communes comme
par exemple le ramassage des ordures et
les transports publics ou la
construction d'équipements locaux comme
des piscines ou des stations d'épuration
des eaux
on parle alors d'une antelle communal et
et associatives ou de gestion second
objectif l'opère communalité regroupe
des communes autour d'un projet de
développement local qui favorise
l'aménagement du territoire on parle
alors d'intercommunalité fédérative ou
deux projets
une commune peut-elle appartenir à
plusieurs intercommunalités n'ont aucune
commune ne pas faire partie que d'une
seule intercommunalité
t comment fonctionne une autre commune
ont lutté une intercommunalité est
organisée de la manière suivante un
organe des libéraux appelé aussi le
conseil communautaire un exécutif et les
services le conseil de libéraux ou
conseil communautaire vote le budget et
se réunit au moins une fois par
trimestre il est composé des conseillers
communautaires
d'où le nombre est fixé par la loi sur
la base du total des habitants de
l'intercommunalité
chaque commune doit avoir au moins un
conseiller est une commune ne peut avoir
plus de la moitié des sièges du conseil
communautaire
les conseillers sont élus à la réunion
comme dans toutes les communes depuis
2000 habitants pour la première fois en
2014 lors des élections municipales au
suffrage universel direct
il doit donc y avoir sur le même
bulletin de vote
deux listes distinctes l'une pour les
conseillers municipaux et le retrait
pour les conseillers communautaires
cette dernière de respecter une parité
en étant composée alternativement d'un
candidat de chaque sexe
l'organe exécutif est composé du
président et du bureau
ils sont élus par le conseil
communautaire le président prépare et
exécute et délibérations il est aussi le
chef des services de l'intercommunalité
il est assisté de biskri vidéo dont le
nombre ne peut pas être supérieure à 20%
des conseillers quant au service ce sont
l'ensemble des personnels qu'ils
exécutent les missions de
l'intercommunalité
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est une intercommunalité
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode
ja